a great race okay one two three go wow
[Music]
that was amazing I would hi I'm Hannah
and I'm the world's OKs mom did you know
that single mother households make up
23% of the u.s. population that's a lot
of single moms and I want to know how
they do it so Matt is leaving on a
business trip for a whole week and I'm
gonna take that time to see what my life
would be like if I were to become a
single mom right now a little bit
nervous but I'm gonna try it seven days
two kids one mom let's do it so Matt is
gonna be gone for one full week and in
that full week it's gonna be just me and
in order to make this week as authentic
as possible did a little research on
single moms and I found out that in 2011
the meaning income for married mothers
was $80,000 for single moms it was four
times less so what I did was calculate
my income as the sole income of our
household and after factoring out rent
and daycare and insurance and all those
expenses i divided what I had left by
four and gave myself that amount to
spend for that week right off the bat
that meant that my babysitter who I paid
to pick up the kids every day from
school was off the table I could not
afford her for that week no I hired her
to pick up the kids so that I don't have
to leave work early to pick them up and
she just has him for a little bit but
that little bit was way too much for me
to even have any money left over for
that week and even further I decided not
to rely on my family for that week
because for a lot of people they don't
have family nearby or they don't have
family members who stay home and are
able to help out with the kids full-time
for free that's your big break
your big break my big break I can watch
all the Forensic Files I want yeah we
said our goodbyes and I realized right
as you walked out the door I needed to
go to Target so it is 8 o'clock in the
evening and we are going to target all
of us together Oh Jackson hit his face
scootering I've both kids it's past our
bedtime usually I would leave them at
home and run out but we need some stuff
for tomorrow and I have to take them one
now parents know when you go to Target
with your kids like walking a tightrope
target is not only a parent's shopping
paradise it's a kid's shopping paradise
so it's just like the worst of both
world come on let's keep going Jackson
Jackson we're only here for a couple
things ok I needed two things at Target
and so I was determined to go in and out
with two things it is 9:30 we got a
little sidetracked at the video game
section I had to shoot down a couple
hopes and dreams we're running a little
late pretty behind for tonight
definitely not doing this to Ken so I'm
just flat on my back exhausted off that
target run today was pretty tough target
was difficult now would be about the
time that I passed that time off to Matt
so that I can relax but it's just me so
we're gonna do cuddles cuddles yeah good
first day huh good night guys okay nice
this morning was rough what are you
shoving some nails live to say the least
let's get socks on come on let's get
socks on so we got Wyatt dropped off
finally very late and now we're heading
to my work and Jackson is on spring
break so he's coming with me to the
office because I don't know what else to
do with him if you are a working parent
and you know the answer to this leave it
in the comments
what the heck do you do with your kid on
school vacations where do you put them
because Jackson had one day left of
spring break so I just hauled him in the
car and took him to work so as you're
walking into the office I realized that
I forgot to fix Jackson's hair and he
dressed himself Jackson you're rocking
it you look awesome
Jackson noticed and so kindly pointed
out to me as kids often do my you are
living downtown I take the shirt because
they didn't sleep in it it's like the
parent equivalent of walk of shame but
it was clean when I slept in it and I
was clean when I put it on so it's still
clean the next day Jackson was so easy
at my office that day we had a great day
got home got ready for bed and then I
had a choice to make I really should get
up and clean and do some dishes and
laundry and stuff but I'm so tired right
now I just want to sleep on this couch
so I think I'm gonna put everything off
for one more day okay we're in the car
on our way to get these forms I need
this paperwork I need we finally you
know we are not going to Target I
learned my last day but I have to get
gas I have a call that I'm gonna have to
take in the car on the way I'm just a
mess so after all the errands I ran into
that same issue of what do I do with my
kids alright well I've just completely
given up on the idea of going into the
office today
it is one o'clock and they're hungry so
they need to be fed I think we're gonna
charge you a drive-thru which they'll be
really excited about because we don't do
that very often and it's reasonable it's
within my budget for this week so that's
what we're gonna do I would love a nap
and a bath I decided to work from home
the rest of the day because like I said
my company is very flexible with the
fact that I'm a parent they're very
understanding and it's not something I
like to do regularly but it's something
that they allow me to do if I absolutely
need to
so while
I had the luxury of working from home
actually getting the work done was a
whole different story because so rainy
the kids cannot play outside today guys
just give me five minutes to get my work
done please please Jackson please I'm
just trying to get a little work done
and I hear banging and crashing in their
room and they have managed to completely
empty their closet and dump everything
on the floor and now I have this on top
of all the other mess it was a
frustrating day day four was a great day
started off with Wyatt not cooperating
with me at all you're not listening to
me I asked you to sit down at the table
please
Wyatt
[Music]
Wyatt I realize that in my rush to get
ready this morning and accessorized with
this necklace and actually get dressed I
forgot my purse
I'm such dummy like I'm the biggest dodo
on the planet who forgets their purse
I'm really nervous about driving without
a license [ __ ] gonna drive my car yes
because he's the best friend in the
entire world and that's what friends are
for we are home so that night it was
white versus chicken nuggets he's not
happy about my dinner choice that I
threw in the oven today but you know
what you can deal with it because that's
what I'm making because it's easy and
that's what we have and that's it do you
like chicken nuggets yeah what you'll
learn to love chicken nuggets he just
doesn't like them because I said I'm
making them so day five I decided to
start the day with a little treat we had
a little money in our budget to get
something inexpensive to go out to eat
so I took them out for breakfast so we
got bagels and I got a little coffee and
I took them to this coffee place that I
know has some toys where they can kind
of run around and build blocks and do a
bunch of stuff and get out some energy
because we had to make another target
trip that day so we got in and Wyatt
because of his age kids that age will
get fixated on something and just not be
able to let go of it so that target run
it was I want boxers you wear a diaper
still kid come on it started with a lot
boxers and then throughout the trip it
turned into zoos and then by the time we
were checking out it was
[Music]
and then in the parking lot it just got
even worse my approach to parenting and
meltdowns is always to treat them with
love because I feel like at Wyatt's age
he's three and he he doesn't understand
but sometimes it just doesn't work and
sometimes nothing works you just have to
write it out and a lot of the time I see
parents you know trying to get their
errands done with a kid melting down in
the cart and other people are looking at
them like why don't you do something
about that but sometimes doing something
makes it worse that was one of those
meltdowns where I just had to not engage
I don't know what to do now I chose to
film a few seconds of it because I feel
like it's something very real that a lot
of parents experience so while it was
tough on Wyatt and it's not a fun thing
to watch it was also really tough on me
it is taking all of my patience in my
entire body to not completely snap right
now so the morning of day six was pretty
much the lowest point of the week for me
so I don't know if you guys can tell
from my eyes but I kind of had a little
meltdown last night kind of like kind of
lost it didn't shower so I'm trying to
last-minute shower this morning boys are
fighting out there but it just it all
got kind of overwhelming last night and
I was just like I don't it's only a week
you know I should be able to do this all
by myself for a week but it's just that
there are not enough hours in the day to
get my job done and then pick up the
kids and do the rest of it there are
just not enough hours in the day and
I need help it's become so apparent they
don't I they not even tired I I have a
harder time getting them to do stuff
than Matt does and it's become very
apparent so I decided that day to make a
concerted effort to do better with the
kids what are we doing we're playing
video games yeah yes sometimes you need
to practice a little self-care and
distract your kids with video games
while you shower you're doing great I'm
not playing some parents are against
video games but to be honest they don't
even really know how to play them oh
they just like click a couple buttons
and they think they're doing something
and they're really happy with it how do
you feel about this whyatt ready ready
[Music]
so day 7 last day was a good day it was
not raining so we whipped out the boys
little landspeeder that they can drive
and I sat outside and let them drive
around for a really long time and then I
also got them this really awesome toy we
have a rare moment of peace and quiet I
got the boys some rocks and laughing me
and I'm like oh you got something there
digging for crystals it was this little
rock a kit and it was about six dollars
best money I've ever spent my head then
put on their PJs and get ready for bed
and right before they went to bed Matt
came home
[Music]
all right hi we had a great week I will
tell you next week good bye guys bye I
did miss you back all right MA
thank you for coming back I almost
didn't I so what did I learn this week I
tried to make things as hard on myself
as possible for this whole week but I
fully recognized that I only scratched
the surface I'm doing this already in a
career that I've achieved because I had
a partner help me while raising our
children I'm already at an advantage
with that and that's something I
couldn't change or take away while I was
juggling my job and both kids I realized
that most single moms have two jobs or
two jobs and they're going to school
full-time or they're just going to
school full-time and trying to figure
out how to pay for everything
I didn't even remotely experience how
difficult it actually is I also learned
that my kids are a lot more resilient
and mature than I thought Jackson really
stepped up that week as a six-year-old
and as my oldest to really take
responsibility for himself and help out
as much as he could with his brother
thank you for helping me he's really
empathetic and so when I'm having a hard
time he really notices I love you sorry
I'm having a hard time today okay
and last I realized that sometimes it's
embarrassing to ask for help and if you
have a single parent in your life my
suggestion would be to offer help I
found myself not asking for help so many
times throughout the week because I felt
embarrassed and I didn't want to burden
people and I feel like that happens a
lot with parents it's up to us to
proactively offer help and find little
things that we can just do maybe it's
just taking the kids for an hour to the
park while the parent takes a nap just
little things will make all the
difference and its really on us to help
each other out
[Music]
that's all I got for today I'm Hannah
and if you are a single parent let us
know in the comments and let us know
what we can do to help or if you know a
single parent or you're raised by a
single parent shout them out in the
comments or you can always text me this
is a real number and I do read every
single text now if you'll please excuse
me I have a week's worth of laundry left
to finish and I feel like I'm going to
lose my mind till next time
[Music]
is there Christmas water in here nobody
awarded
[Music]